PREDICTABLY THE ESTABLISHMENT
IS BLAMING PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HIS SUPPORTERS FOR CLIMATE OF
RAGE AND HATE.
LET'S BE HONEST.
A LOT OF AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
ANGRY FOR A LONG TIME.
I'M THINKING PARTICULARLY OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WHO STRUGGLE
FOR GENUINE DIGNITY AND
FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY IS A
VERY LONG WAY FROM OVER.
I'M ALSO THINKING OF WORKING
AMERICANS WHOSE ECONOMIC
SECURITY HAS COLLAPSED AND
OPPORTUNITIES HAVE DISAPPEARED
AND SOCIAL FABRIC IS
ESPECIALLY FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN RIPPED
APART.
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON SINCE
EARLY 1970.
THAT'S NEARLY HALF A CENTURY.
IN 2008 USE OF THE ELITE BAIL
THEMSELVES OUT WHILE WORKING
PEOPLE PAID THE PRICE FOR
THEIR RECKLESSNESS.
ANDREW SAW A NEW TONE INTO OUR
POLITICS.
OTHERS MADE CLEAR THEY LOVE
AMERICA AND LOVES AMERICANS,
ALL AMERICANS.
REAGAN, BUSH, BILL CLINTON,
THEY WEREN'T HATERS.
YOU GOT THE SENSEI LOVED
EVERYBODY BUT THEM WITH
SOMETHING NEW, A CULTURAL
ELITISM AMEN.
CONDESCENSION AND EVEN
CONTEMPT LIKE THIS, AND THIS
WE MEANT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
MY ADULT LIFETIME I'M REALLY
PROUD OF MY COUNTRY.
PAIRED REMEMBER FROM THE.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> DAY, NOT YOU HAVE AN ALLY
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS TIME THEY HAVE AN ALLY.
THERE'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, PURULENT
PEOPLE,
PEOPLE -- PURULENT PEOPLE.
AND THE QUEEN OF HATE, THE
EMPRESS OF DIVISIVENESS.
>> YOU CAN PUT HALF THE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS IN THE BASKET OF
DEPLORABLE.
>> I HAVE NEVER HEARD
REPUBLICANS TALK ABOUT FELLOW
AMERICANS LIKE THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE NEVER
TALKED ABOUT FELLOW AMERICANS
LIKE THAT.
YES HE'S USED HARSH LANGUAGE,
BUT HE'S NEVER TALK LIKE THAT
ABOUT PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
EVER SINCE 2008, WORKING
AMERICANS STARTED TO REALIZE
THE PEOPLE AT THE TOP, THE
POLITICIANS AND THE CEOS IN
THE TECH GENIUSES IN HOLLYWOOD
TYPE REALLY DO LOOK DOWN THEIR
NOSES AT THEM FOR HOW THEY
LIVE, WHAT THEY EAT AND WHAT
THEY WATCH AND THAT THEY GO TO
CHURCH.
I'M PART OF THE ELITE.
I SIT AT THEIR DINNER TABLES
AND HEAR HOW THEY SPEAK.
LET'S TELL THE TRUTH.
I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
DIRECTLY TO MY FRIENDS IN THE
ELITE.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT TRUMP.
IT'S ABOUT YOU TWO.
THE WAVES SHOW NO COMPASSION
FOR THE CASUALTY OF YOUR IDEAS
OF GLOBALIZATION,
CENTRALIZATION AND
UNCONTROLLED IMMIGRATION.
IT'S DEVASTATED FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES.
AND WHEN THEY CRY OUT FOR
HELP, YOU CALL THEM DEPLORABLE
THE ELITES HAVE JUMPED ON A
TWEET FROM TOM HANKS TODAY.
HE WAS IN A PITTSBURGH
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE THIS
TERRIBLE SHOOTING TOOK PLACE
WHICH HAPPENED TO BE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD MR. ROGERS LIVED
IN TOM HANKS PLAYED HIM IN A
RECENT MOVIE.
HE SAW A SIGN OF THE WINDOW,
LOVE THY NEIGHBOR, NO
EXCEPTIONS.
START PRACTICING THE TOLERANCE
YOU REACH.
SHOW SOME EMPATHY AND
RESPECT.